okay thank you it's a Berkeley's day ah
this talk is off topic you know that
there's a rule that you should never
start a talk by apologizing but there's
no rule saying that you can't start a
talk by blaming somebody else they may
be organizers Kostya okay
that model of a real world network 23
starts off as a graph this is totally
weird why do people do this because I
tell you if you take your a hundred
favorite real world networks and think
about them and at least ninety five of
them a better thought of as a edge
weighted graphs the things just to have
it edge weights attached to them in
almost any context you can think of
hellish numbers in the collaboration
graph your help have you actually
written the joint paper with somebody
else well you can say that is a zero one
thing but maybe you know how many papers
have you written or how long are those
papers or how many how long have they
been cited its actual natural to think
of it that way and this goes to almost
anything you can think of so why don't
people do this and partly it's habit of
course but i think the actual more
substantive reason is that the actual
interpretation of apes is very different
in different context and you can think
of you 30 different types of
interpretation edge weight so we're
familiar with the max-flow min-cut with
a some notion of a flow or the capacity
roads or your water distribution network
you've got big and small loads because
small pipes where we think of traveling
salesman problem to type examples we're
thinking of the weight on there just
being a distance or a cost something
we're trying to minimize the third
contacts which is what I'm talking about
is where I'm thinking of the waiters
these of strength of association between
the two vertices use so in particular
I'm thinking social networks where
vertices are people I'm thinking of some
relationship Lucy like friendship we
have a standard example of facebook
friend as a sort of lowest level of
friendship and when I was very different
higher levels of friendship here and
again its own that natural do a little
thinker it's not a zero one relationship
is my quantitative relationship again so
when I mentioned collaboration networks
you know people who study real about
network study lots of things like this
you can look at corporate the
directorships and your how many
corporations are you on the same border
as or you can look at your senators
voting records and sort of what
proportion of the times it was the same
way on different ways so there are sort
of hand moves of things like this and
even lot of biological networks so you
can talk about the ecological networks
what eats what well if you're a bear or
a go to basically eat anything so it's
somehow not useful just to say what do
you eat you want to think in terms of
condonation firms how much of your diet
is something else so again i'm looking
at the class of graphs where you know an
edge indicates an association but we
have a consultative measure of strength
through association let's go get it as
even these examples even when you can do
that you know kind of what's the
implications of your one strength of
association being twice as much as
another means this context dependent
what does it mean to say I'm for twice
as much of a friend with but with person
a than with person B and my attempted
abstracting this doing ray abstract
mafia is to interpret strength of
associations the frequency of
interaction so if I interact with you
you twice as much as with somebody else
then that's what I mean by being by
having a twice a strong edge way to the
first white button here so to make
random this I'm thinking of the times of
these interactions as purely random the
time of a Phaethon process of some
weight and the weight of the Poisson
process it is
it is that valida and that's the meaning
about edge wait here aside this sort of
notion of a interaction is I wats at the
base of water mystical physicists and
travel this think of us interacting
particle systems where you think of
individuals having some internal state
and when two individuals interact their
tapes are updated recordings or some
rule and this all goes back to using
type models in these eventual lattice
and kind of over the last 20 years this
is sort of started merging with these
studies of what other people call social
dynamics with this fiber from models
things like the photo models on the
basic epidemic bottles that's one
direction you can go from this framework
I'm going a different direction so I'm
just thinking at the network level
mostly without kind of states and
focuses on top of that or I'll give one
example where we do talk about that so I
saw us and we just interested in some
quantitative feature of a network and we
could just calculate that if we knew
what network was but we don't sorry
what's good sorry facility which are you
given the w/e so you given oh no you I'm
about to say that you're given the
vertices and nothing else like you start
off okay let me guess I never get to the
ex parte ok so the like the very big
question is you know what do we do if we
have an imperfectly observed network how
well can we estimate things which we'd
which we could calculate if we knew what
network was gonna call at the
imperfectly observed network problem
people obviously have thought about this
before you can't be the first person to
think of something simple like that so
they're different ways people have
thought about it i'll mention one
popular way later but i'm just going to
talk about the way i want to think about
it so they're not claiming this is you
saw the real world data investing as
math theory
so my more precise set up a network as a
finite edge weighted graph I'm concerned
with some statistic or a metric on there
just a number you can associate with any
touch graph or functional on graphs so
there's some true network which we we
can't see but for simplicity we will
suppose we know the vertices and we
start watching this and what we're
seeing is the interaction process
described above for preacher preach pair
of vertices which potential edge that
there's a wait if it's zero then we
don't have any interactions at all if
the age of eight ER isn't zero we're
seeing interactions as a Poisson process
of rate that w/e so somehow i start off
seeing this and then i see an
interaction here an infection there an
interaction there is some natural to
draw these interactions just to say
edges so at some time I've after a
little time I've seen I know an observed
when the multi graph of this type and
one way of representing the data is as a
multi graph of course if I observed this
vast river then the law of large numbers
data tells me that I can just sort of
estimate what all the edge weights are
the edge weight is the asymptotic number
of interactions for unit time so time T
I just look at this or observed dumb of
interactions few minutes the unit time
which is just a number of interactions
divided by T so if I can think of this
so I can think about observationally
either is this when the multigraph owes
a random weighted graph where these are
three edges here I have one edge of
weight 3 over T attached to it that's
the same with same story so how issue is
when I
bezar drawing what I've seen here if I
see something like this on a bigger
scale and the some aspect of the true
graph I want to know then sort of how
well can I estimate it from from Bissell
observed process okay i'm doing this is
a statistical issue general comment i
should say there was no technical stuff
in this the papers mostly words or the
toxicity words here again it's a bit
this is a general framework because
there any question about networks llego
interested in if you can do a version
where you sort of see network is no you
can also go up and say what happens if
we don't know the network as Mason the
father other ways of thinking about what
an imperfectly observed network is I'll
say it later ah the first thing you
think of doing it is to say well that's
just some estimate the edge weights so
this is what i was saying here i just
observe this for some time if i see
three interactions in time T I can it
might I love my estimate which according
to your philosophical view points you
can call the sort of natural estimate or
the naive frequentist a estimate of the
edge of a disparity so you have a filet
estimated later graph and I can just
apply in my statistic to the estimated
graph the trouble from a statistics
point of view and I'm from out of
character do i suspend my life saying
you know I just I'm not a statistician I
just work in the Cystic department but
uh here i'm wearing my statistics
t-shirts i'm claiming to be a
statistician temporarily yeah so mean
from a physical point of view we have
some complicated nonlinear function van
der amateurs and the idea of well yes
the right the parameters separately i
defy the non linear functional you know
sort of that's not stupid but there's
been there no reason to leave that's the
optimal way of estimating a non linear
functional so it may well need a better
ways of doing it and we'll see one
example where they clearly is the other
extreme we always have a naive Bayes
estimator being evasion you get rid of
one bunch of problems and creates
another one so i'll talk a bit about
that
the end if we have time I'm off topic to
this lecture because I'm not concerned
the computational complexity like
computation is free so a cost here it's
just the observation time users are
cheap but setting up to the observations
will compare up so to start formulating
an actual question whatever estimator we
use sometimes amo is going to depend if
we observe for a fixed time T and then
make an estimate or than the others
obviously understand I'm not the unknown
true graph is and we saw don't want that
so we formulate this is on an online
problem I want to say that you know I
don't know anything about the graph I
want to a rule that says you win to stop
observing it and announce some estimator
and I want to th no guarantee that the
firm relative error of the estimator it
is small with high probability but so
totally uniformly of all networks so I'm
asking for something very strong here I
wants to be a uniform of all possible
networks and that's the kind of way I'm
saying a math problem here let me repeat
that the program again modifying the
talk is that I should have no idea how
to do this for interesting things that's
why lots of open problems here but we
can do it for a few statistics which are
suggestive I should also say this is
ongoing joint work with kind of student
alysha leigh see here Oh DJ ok ok ok I
think she's actually teaching a lab or
something
yeah okay so good I want to do some kind
of discussion to get the idea of orders
of magnitude so there's some sort otal
interaction wait with the rest of
society of a given individual the WV to
make sense of things I mean time this
video we can scale these rates are value
up or down so in continuous time so some
time doesn't make any sense without some
standardization for the session purposes
let's just assume all these total
interaction rates of a person are one
that makes sense of times and time T
we're seeing on average T edges for
vertex and number vertices getting large
positively there are three different
time machines if T is little o of one if
you get small and a sibrel vertex you
haven't seen anything so we can't say
much about the graph when you haven't
seen any edges at a given vertex if you
remember the birthday problem says that
a time water n to the minus half you
start seeing a few vertices with more
than one edge this enables you to start
getting information about the degree
distribution or thats related analog
event degree distribution so if T is
only just little over one you can
basically observe things like the life
you can observe things like the degree
the distribution of the degrees of
vertices and it's a lots of triangles
you can start doing other local
statistics of relative numbers of
triangles so you can't do much more than
that the c equals 0 1 the other extreme
by the coupon collectors problem
typically if you want to your observed
graph to be connected we need to go up
to time for a login and at that time of
course we having auto login Oh edges per
vertex if I think loosely about the
sparse graph setting say what that means
it is fast graph setting where the sort
of maximum age rates of the vertex and
vanishingly small then we've seen sort
of film or a lot log in a moment
we have good estimates of the large
estimated waves and roughly speaking I'm
studying here in this in this rate
regime we can start estimating anything
well so the interesting regimes where t
is the largest constant if your
surveillance agency with a three letter
acronym that's getting metadata for your
phone calls then at issue is on what
what what what can you tell when you've
seen or 13 or 57 phone calls between
people what can you say about the
structure of the graph there okay so the
problem I'd like to do and can't do is a
connectivity problem so I suppose we
sort of run this weekend up to some
sorting time say and we will observe
that we've got uh some highly connected
in some sense giant vertex set so so
again if we have average degree 13 then
somehow we are probably not completely
connected but we have a connected set of
size 99% of n if we focus not only that
but we couldn't sort of find maybe some
vertex set of size sort of 98% n which
is sort of highly connected some
unspecified side and we like to infer
that the true graph and has some similar
giant and but except that's highly
connected
so we conjecture that something like
this is true the reason we think
something like this is true it's the
idea that the randomness in going from
the true graphed the observed graph
randomness to make things less well
connected and therefore if we observe
that it ends up well connected but
that's well connected than the true
graph then the two gap has to be oh well
connected now this one weird logic in
here which will say later but that's the
intuition but we can't venue reasonable
version of this at all okay so changing
gears so there's a sideways approach to
a phonogram that gives us some odd
results I'm saying say to results in
parallel I'm thinking of representing
observe oh but our observation process
as this or growing multigraph process we
see war more interactions and draw in
the edges I have these two sobbing times
to find the first time I see hey edge
disjoint copies of some structure here
rather extreme ones the triangles and
spanning trees what they do the same
thing for any structure of course a
disjointed i can use of different car
copies of the different edges between
the same vertex pair and the proposition
below says that if i look at the how
these are concentrated in terms of
standard deviation over expectation and
again i have to think of things in this
form because you know i can scale all my
weights and that scales all the times
linearly scale laugh at those out and
these are just absolutely bounded in a
way that goes down by with k in a
particular way so these are totally
independent of what the true graph is a
totally independent of the waves and
what this is saying so i could think of
this as sort of a concentrate a week
from the concentration right
inequalities she possibly are
interesting Wadley but inactive contact
top it says is that if i want to
estimate the the statistics so the
expectation of these things are weird
not 60 natural statistics of the graph
but their statistics of a graph and what
these are saying is that i can estimate
these
I simply running the process and using
the random time itself as yesterday that
I have bounded ever of course yesterday
to defend the accuracy depends on okay
but if I want to never only a third as
big I just have to do it nine times and
rely on it independently basically keep
on running absorb patient process so i
can make the Apprendi ki can make the
bounds of estimators arbitrarily small
by just repeating independently a bunch
of times so this is the kind of sideways
approach to it but if you can find a any
anything like this any song cystogram
process which is improve its always
concentrated around us me and then sort
by definition you have a restoration
procedure here so i'm going to say a
little getting in words out at silence
and Delta's about where this comes from
a partly because there's an open problem
I wants to circulate since tues out of
this archive prevailed so there's an
abstract structure that if I have
something that's like an increasing
set-valued Markov process and I'm
looking at the first time that it's and
increasing set that is a looking for the
first time that this process has a
policy which is sort of close and we're
adding extra edges then we just have a
simple general bound for this week
concentration quantity standard
deviation of expectation to if we apply
this in our context without the first
time we contain k destroyed two objects
and see how far we get without actually
specifying what the objects are we can
get a certain way without specifying
what the objects are and then of course
there's some computation with something
you have to do involving the object i'm
going to say what we have to do in loose
terms at the rhythm of game game this is
a game that turns out to be trivial it
out two examples but not in others so
the game we're playing is that i'm in a2
is a multi graph which has the given
poverty of containing K disjoint objects
here nothing in a disease an edge and
then I'm going to present that graph to
you then I gotta ask
you can you always find many different
ways of restoring the poverty by
creating a few new edges which can be
crazy anywhere they're so fighters of
course we can always do it by okay
creating the h i deleted but that's just
one way of doing it i want lots of
different ways of doing it so in my two
cases so for spanning trees like deleted
the edge of what am i standing to use
that just sort of cuts the vertex set in
the two so in order to get back at a
standing tree I don't have to put back
the attacked edge I delete it all you
have to do is to create some edge
between the links the disorder partition
of the vertex set inside of you have at
least n minus 1 edges to work for four
triangles again you got page disjoint
triangles I move an edge well now I
can't get back that particular triangle
but so there's lots of triangles I'd
like to do so for the triangles case I
just the creates a new triangle
something else with three three edges so
get these are the trivial things I can
do in these cases and what they bound in
the general inequality says is because I
now have bring in the demand and process
I have to think how long does it take
this random process to do this rip
restore operation of either joining
split or creating a new triangle and the
point is that something we can estimate
and relate to the expectation of TK
that's where the argument comes from but
in thinking about doing this with other
properties and that's the one to think
about is the K edge connected poverty so
there's a play this game now we have to
answer the following problem was if I
sorry if I choose a kedge connected
graph I delete an edge I show you the
resulting graph and now is there any
structure theory that tells you that
you're there are a lot of different ways
of creating edges to restore this cage
connected poverty and somehow Mengers
theorem gives equivalent conditions for
being caged connected I don't know if
there's any structure teary-eyed up know
if it's
or as possible to do this or maybe
they're examples but just for it isn't
possible but ask your favorite graph
seriousness they notice how to do this
okay let's move on to more natural
statistics in some traveling salesman
problems the type world where age weight
the costs you talk about minimum weight
matchings here I'm trying to match
people with their friends so the plates
the strength of friendship sly one sort
of maximum wage how matchings so we get
if I'm you know edge weighted graph two
games even matching is the type of n
over two edges of each vertex in the SEC
exactly one edge you all know this the
weight of the matching is what you think
about it the maximum weight is just a
little maximum of matchings of the later
the matching that's a natural cystic of
edge weighted graph can be estimate the
swim I was observed graph so this is the
basic example where there's a live
frequentist estimator it doesn't work it
doesn't work on the dense glass which i
think it was to complete graph with edge
weights whenever n minus 1 normalizing
things such as a total vertex weight is
one got the reason it doesn't work is
that I observed graph at time T I'm
seeing order tea I think all the T if
every office eyes to see a sort of a fat
aunty done the mesh is different and I'm
giving them wait 1 over T and of course
on a graph like this you know I can
basically pick out i created matching
using all the end of the weights 1 over
T and I get my sort of a bias the bat of
the total my base limit of this maximum
weight matching from the observed Wade
your good graph attends to be alright n
over T worse course the true estimate is
sort of a half finally got
n over two edges in the matching and all
the weights are 1 over N so somehow this
stuff doesn't work we are way off in
this particular example here we can
finesse this issue pitch word for sound
better we're going to cheat a little
probably the finesse that sounds good
here by reformulating the problem so we
can say that we imagine real-world
networks is being typically sparse so we
changed the rules a bit by saying we
still want a we've got their estimates
to be valid and it's achieved asserted
ever bounds whatever the true grass is
but we taught only require them to be
sorry informative in the case where the
graph is sparse and this helps us out
again make sure the weighted graph being
as fast as the two fish that's a total
move in faction mates are given the
vertex that the terminated by the sort
of more frequent interactions rather
than a large times were very rare
interactions here as we said the
thinkable buttocks infection rates as
being one then we come back in this type
of situation if you have some of you
have seven friends that then you're the
edge weights to get the order of 1 over
seven and we can do it to a matching
sort of total laterz constant times n so
we get the refund rate the problem is
like estimating the sort of maximum
weight per vertex there's a gamma 1
divided by n and we're going to say we
want to estimate this up to small
additive error so the find is in dense
graphs this is a race of all number
anyway so we're not getting an
informative estimate but we're getting
an estimate that is informative for a
fast graph here course the point in
congratulating or a matching this is at
some point we have to get grips on
estimating with the weights of the
individual of individual edges in the
back in the matching and to do that we
have to have observed them at least
twice there's this world that Savvas
itions call the unseen species problem
the better way of saying it is we know
how many were different words
Shakespeare looks down in his plays and
sonnets we can count them but how many
did he know whom the he knew a bunch of
words he never had occasion to write
down so how do you guesstimate that we
use some statistical model to do that oh
so that's a in a standard do this
project likes the sort of lots of
different areas anyway so that suggests
way to go which is an under system
another user is basically saying when I
look at that when I try out a matching
tie and calculate its weight i'm only
going to count or book edges where I've
seen at these two interactions which
these are for giving me some some useful
information so I take the maximum of
that of all matches and intuition that
turns out to be true is that this is a
good estimate in a sort of slightly
cheating sense up to order n minus 1
very ever that are wherever here is a
bound that just depends on T the best
you can hope for but just like a silly
being of Baffin one edge and the usual
square root laws sees the minus a half
pound and intercept least rate forward
messy arguments show this is true for
some explicit sigh which days roughly as
you think it's going to large t here I'm
finessing details here because of their
zazzle scaling it has to be a scaling
factor from the edge weights on the
maximum edge weight but we can escalate
that quickly so we can apply this
actually without assuming anything if I
all I about the age waves ah Silverio
again mathematically even easier i was
thinking of community structure so again
yet remember i'm ignoring computational
complexity and thinking of Kostas
observation time here
so I can think of a community in terms
of the edge densities or the total the
son of all edge weights between vertices
a in a community divided by the total
number possible but edges m choose to a
big lazy ass a.m. to the minus two so we
have a maximum edge density in size am
communities that is a cystic of the
underlying unknown graph in this case
the naive estimate works well so I said
yesterday this by exactly the same thing
in the observed graph if I want to make
some influence from the observed graph
to the true graph somehow I can't have
em fix then go into infinity because
anything will happen eventually
infertile finite force our finite sets
are concerned so you take the m going up
as order log n then again by various so
straightforward with her arguments we
get a whole cystica confidence interval
again the mandamus sort of XD sings
better make the edge density larger so
the actual sort of you true maxim aah
density is gonna be some are smaller on
the observed one but we can get a an
explicit balance or the roughly half
perform stated here
so one example where this doesn't work
at all just because I don't want to give
to do there's some mixture here this is
about what I think of us one of the two
basic processes building of a basic
maths one of horses the sort of markov
chain continuous line random or from the
weighted graph yes extensive firmly
connected to electrical networks etc but
the other one is little first passage
process the first passage speculation
process again given a fixed a non men de
menthe weighted graph and two
distinguished vertices that'll start and
finish we use the edge weights to create
independent random variables with the
given rates so again the a weight being
large indicates i think they close
together so these variables traversal
times are small when the weights a large
there's the first package time just the
minimum value of the sum of these two
vessel times over all paths that's
random but we can takes expectation and
we think about as a cystic and we start
fixing the vertex sets and the source
and sink we think of this is depending
on the edge weights which are the
unknown things so we can argue that this
is sort of a problem which we can't do
in the ways that we can or conjecture we
can further sistex so the background of
course is that because our observation
processes involving these pass on
posters exponential time so we could
always actually use the observation
process itself to simulate the actual
random fpp time and this gives us sort
of estimates by repeating that a few
times that gives you estimate that
reserver doesn't depend on w at all it's
just that takes a long time to do and
we'd like to do it well quickly in
quicker time and the argument i'll
outline basically yes sir to you you you
you you can't do that at all
with a universal algorithm this you have
to use a drone first suppose I just had
a line graph on some 0 to n with unknown
weights but just the finger than wait
for simplicity or the one then of course
you know what the meantime is some of 1
over the weights and somehow the obvious
way of estimating this it's just the
wait until we've seen at least K
injections across every edge kind of all
works well in this particular case so
you might hope from this example in the
previous examples in general one could
play the same trick one could say we
observe the process until we've seen K
edge disjoint paths from source to sink
and this sort of just doesn't work
because there's a bad graph rapper vs.
is one of this type where I rizal source
at the top and I think at the bottom and
and a bunch of two edge pass the tween
them this is constructed so that the
this observation time needed to make an
estimate of the fpp time it's the same
order as the actual fpp time so you
can't sort of predict in advance here so
what happens is if you so super impose
these two cases so if we think about the
distaff but also with a path of length n
but we saw a quick interpolation times
long each of the edges here then some of
the first thing you see is sort of a lot
of infections along the path of length
from and and that gives you an estimate
of the first at this time along that
particular path and you so don't see the
possibility you see some scattered
unconnected edges here but you saw don't
know they're connected up into paths so
the point is that you couldn't make an
estimate for the actual linear graph
until you sort of ZURB the possible
until you've been able to eliminate the
possibility that there's this structure
you don't see it turns out this is true
you
universally that google it if you claim
you have a universal algorithm if you
play in that sort of any prep for any
grass whatsoever that this algorithm
gives an estimate of the true SPV time
or a lot earlier than the observed fpp
time and sorry I'm messing up these
controls here
then I can kind of construct a
counterexample but by sort of it bye-bye
for constructing an example with my this
type so we are you created such that the
time the preparation time the
observation time is a in the gap between
what when you algorithm made the
prediction and when the first passage
percolation time for the fur your grass
was I can still sneak this in and your
algorithm gives the wrong estimator on
this example so this service there are
some limits the when we can hope to go
through project these handles artificial
of course so maybe you can get rid of
this by sort of start putting some weak
assumptions on w/o more positive sign is
that again a simple connects to the
argument he chose that using the
observed graft western at this fpp time
that it consistently gives you
overestimates rather than under s
Phillips suffice Lee the unconditional
distribution so now for two levels of
randomness there's randomness in the
observed network as well send the
randomness in running the calculation on
that observed network but sort of the
unconditional the distribution of the
fpp time you get out of that it's
stochastically larger than the
distribution of a 2 PP time and that's
encouraging because basically a major
open problem without quantifying
connectivity as we want something
similar in that case and we happen how
to do it in that case with it's sort of
what we want the weird logic I mentioned
by kind of going to insult you all by
claiming as in my experience no one
actually appreciates the logic of
freshman statistics and tests of
significance so you may I gonna find you
anyway so the logic is suppose you have
a theorem of the following type that if
G true has a father DP
then at least nine five percent
probability bility t observed as one of
the latest property p stark same
property with some families has changed
what's the actual influence you can make
from that an infant's you can make from
that is that if you're served does not
have poverty p star then we have some
ninety-five percent confident but
you too has poverty p so this is somehow
what the logic of tests of significance
tells you and it's very not in non
intuitive but that's somehow you leave
am sighs be the same as not be implies
not a we're using that logic that we're
going from poverty through the search of
the confidence which means that because
infrequent this world you can't make
probability statements about parameters
if this does not good see I see it so
hard I thought of you this is so not
sure then you may you make even though
you think you understand that you start
saying stupid things you improving my
own party the g 20 not 30 p cessor logic
that the point is a print fence we want
to make your positive assertions so
again we sort of i want to end up with
saying i want to make an influence but
if it does have a poverty maybe to
change the queue these are the queue
then i want to say i'm ninety-five
percent confident the g2 does have
poverty i actually make this up mess
this up I didn't prepare to do this g2
has poverty Q star
oh so what the theorem that corresponds
to that infants so it's sort of we want
to say this do g2 there's no not have
fun buddy you start messing this up
thoroughly here fala d q star then with
ninety-five percent probability he
observed not a father like you okay I
think I got that right but it's
unintuitive you've ever wondered why
people become days yawns and so this is
why people become bayesian is because
this on logic is sort of so it's on
traverse to actually so think about here
some of my fighters and some what is it
we have to do to sort of mysore
connectivity but conjecture the natural
way you if you work on random ass that's
the way you do is thinking of you I
wants to prove that you my mother by
random graph has a nice holiday so you
somehow think that what is refined
approval today if the true graph has a
nice fixing poverty there now observed
graph had a nice mixing poverty but why
we actually need to prove is the other
way around if you want to make the
influence of about this for nice mixing
qualities or the other theory have to
prove is that if the unknown true graph
it fails some desirable the mixing
poverty then the observed graph also is
going to fail that so it's just sort of
hard to keep going keep this logic in
mind okay that's my lecture here
Oh out of time here have anything else
interesting on here ah just as-a or
what's in the literature imperfectly
observe networks so here's a survey
righted 683 times I stop they call the
link prediction problem so here they do
that they're looking at with your butt
unmated grass and then they're suppose
there's no strips down version is lets
you know the vertices and all the edges
you see a really they're the only
problem is they may be unobserved edges
so they formulate this problem in a
quite different way the goal is the sort
of write an algorithm that takes or
observed edges an input and an output
list of all the sort of bond edges or
other things you haven't seen all the
possible edges in decreasing order of
some perceived likelihood of the edge
being present so how do you do that well
basically you had a look at little
neighborhood sistex so anytime you have
a pair of vertices that are not we're
don't have an edge between them you kind
of look at the neighborhoods of both the
vertices and see if they have vertices
in in common there are many ways of
doing that but you basically look at
some cystic affairs of ever sees
depending typical local structure of the
graph and then you sort of simply you
output the knowledge is in sort of order
of this cystic so the point is that
there's no probability bottle involve
the tall so just an algorithm so how do
you test it out with emily do it
empirically you take advantage of
real-world networks and you then sort of
randomly delete some portion of the
edges from the real world network and so
feed them to the algorithm and then just
see how well the algorithm actually does
in reconstructing from this sort of
synthetic observed graft the thinking
about real graphs randomly lead to their
edges so this ends although i don't know
if they're actually 683 versions of this
a cystic here but there are a lot of
versions people have played around
you have a little competition whose
algorithm miss pipe what works best so
this is is this has no liability model
would be involved so it's hard to make
time to say anything in our world about
this I mean I'm working with the
probability model but of course it's a
rather unrealistic fabulet evilly itself
so there's a things and roundabouts
there okay I'll stop there thank you
very much questions yes how
your specification of an imperfectly
observed network starts empty and you
watch the data come in yet but there are
lots of real-world networks where we
have an existing the mountains of data
and new data is coming in and the old
data is becoming stale and wrong okay do
all the same sets of questions arise and
can you work them into the same family
okay but saying the old data is wrong
you're saying that network is actually
changing in time William ibly yeah okay
I can follow that but body having now
has a certain thing so I thought I
concept of good now yeah you're right
and that just adds another level of good
complexity because the den issue is are
you going to make a sniffing bottle of
how the network is changing so what I
like about this framework because I'm
trying to it universally over finite
grass without any assumptions on the
graphs but no and the idea that if you
now want the graph to change in time if
you also have no assumptions on the
graph is changing in time it's very hard
to see you could prove anything but
somehow you have to you if you start
making a probability bottle of how
things to change in time but then you're
somehow implicitly I don't know your
yo-yo you entering this slightly
different world but there certainly is a
problem you could think about if you had
some specific motivation to think about
it
the questions
all right it's time for a break and
we'll be back a little while for the
finals of the world